[Musique]
bonsoir à tous la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire est l'invité et
d'auditions publiques madame vergon
bonsoir bonsoir et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté l'invitation des chaînes
parlementaires du figaro et de la sp
vous êtes également bien sûr rôle c'est
depuis quelques semaines chargées
d'organiser et bien oui ou de veiller à
la bonne marche du grand débat avec
votre collègue sébastien lecornu
d'ailleurs vous étiez il ya quelques
heures avec les restos du coeur vous
êtes en charge notamment des
associations
oui je n'ai plus particulièrement de
même de la mobilisation pardon de la
société civile et à l'heure du déjeuner
j'étais avec des bénévoles et des
salariés des restos du coeur avec nos
âmes un griveaux pour discuter grands
débats et situation des personnes en
situation de pauvreté par rapport à ce
débat d'accord alors le grand débat sera
au coeur de la première partie
d'auditions publiques avec mathilde de
sirop du figaro c'était paul briat de la
sp bonsoir à tous deux bonsoir les
dossiers environnementaux
madame wargon et notamment la question
du du rythme d'une transition qui se
fait attendre
selon certains on en parlera tout à
l'heure avec orianne mancini et brigitte
boucher de public sénat et de lcp
assemblée nationale
et puis bien sûr comme chaque semaine il
y aura dans une vingtaine de minutes les
interpellations de deux parlementaires
la sénatrice socialiste laurence
rossignol et le député et l'air robin
reda et bien sûr si vous suivez cette
émission sur le figaro là et vous pouvez
réagir à travers le chat et je me ferais
bien sûr comme chaque semaine le relais
de vos interpellations et de vos
interrogations pour notre invité d'abord
aimer dargaud est ce que vous dites à
ses stops
après un nouveau samedi de
manifestations avec la casse qui va avec
les agressions et les violences est ce
que vous dites stop notamment face à
l'antisémitisme qui semble se répandre
avec des actes
odieux sinistre comme on l'a vu dans le
xiiie arrondissement aujourd'hui des
croix gammées porté sur le portrait de
simone veil
on n'a pas de mots pour dire ce qu'on
ressent quand on voit le portrait de
simone veil défiguré par une croix
gammée
bien sûr je dis stop bien sûr je suis
atterré terrifié même par ce retour de
la violence de la violence antisémite et
bien sûr je dis stop
globalement aux violences qui s'exprime
le week end on est maintenant dans le
temps de l'apaisement des dans le temps
de la construction mais on a
l'impression que les gens ne comprennent
même pas là la porte et la violence
symbolique et physique de ce qui se
passe il faut que ça s'arrête dire stop
c'est une chose il faut s'indigner bien
évidemment mais ça ne peut pas suffi
vous êtes aux gouvernements quels moyens
d'action avez-vous c'est bien la raison
pour laquelle le ministre de l'intérieur
fait ces opérations de maintien de
l'ordre et de maintien de l'ordre public
tous les week-ends c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle le texte sur la loi dite
anti casseur est à l'assemblée nationale
en ce moment ces violences qui
s'expriment maintenant chaque samedi
est ce que donne l'impression que
certains partis politiques sont
comprises envers son appel les casseurs
au bout de 13 actes des jv jaune et des
violences qui qui qui s'ils accompagnent
est-ce que vous pointez de
responsabilités politiques danser dans
cette violence en tout cas pour moi il
est extrêmement important que tous les
partis soient maintenant extrêmement
claire dans la dénonciation du racisme
de l'antisémitisme de la violence et le
temps rozès toute complaisance il ya pu
avoir de la complaisance de voudrait
maintenant d'abord possible oui vous
vous dites stop mais alors à qui vous
vous adressez laquelle parti d extrême
pour moi les très précisément pour pour
moi les vacances vous les aurez extrêmes
certains membres de la france insoumise
certains membres du rassemblement
national ont pu
né à penser qu'il s'excusait une forme
de violence sous une forme ou sous une
autre il faut que ça cesse bon moment
des gigues et jaune il a encore
populaire dans l'opinion il ya grosso
modo encore une majorité de français qui
soutiennent ce mouvement est ce que ça
vous surprend après ces violences dont
ont parlé et malgré le fait que ça fasse
désormais treize semaines que ça dure
pour moi il ya deux choses qui sont très
différentes
un soutien aux revendications est
l'expression de la colère porté par les
gilet jaune à savoir la difficulté à
joindre les deux bouts
la volonté d'être considérés respectés
et ça ça m'étonne pas qu'il reste un
soutien populaire et la violence je ne
crois pas que les gens soutiennent la
violence je crois que la violence c'est
un phénomène très limité et je ne pense
pas qu'il ya un soutien public
comment on fait comment est ce qu'on
peut continuer comme ça avec chaque
samedi des manifestations
d'un côté un grand débat plutôt policé
et à chaque fois des agressions des
actes violents
est ce qu'on peut attendre encore comme
ça toutes les semaines chaque samedi
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour trouver une
issue c'est toute la difficulté des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
moi je voudrais vraiment rendre hommage
aux forces de police aux forces de
gendarmerie qui tous les samedis sont
sur le pont et qui cherche à à la fois
permettre aux français d'exercer leur
droit de manifestation et à la fois
contenir la violence c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle on est obligés de
développer l'arsenal législatif pour
trouver la manière d'encadrer au mieux
c'est la fameuse interdiction de
manifester dont on voit bien qu'elle est
nécessaire puisqu'on voit bien que ces
manifestations n'arrive pas à se
canaliser par elle même on voit par
exemple des manifestants qui peuvent se
faire filmer toute la journée pour
autant et ils commettent des actes de
vandalisme comment on peut expliquer ça
aux français non peux pas l'expliquer un
mois que je suis extrêmement choquée de
sage autant le droit de manifestation
c'est une liberté fondamentale et chacun
a le droit d'exprimer son opinion et
d'aller manifester dans la rue s'ils
considèrent qu'il y eût elle n'est pas
bien traité par le gouvernement
par le pouvoir politique autant le
vandalisme impunis c'est juste pas
acceptable c'est ce contre quoi on se
bat tous les samedis est ce que vous
attendez puisque paul faisait référence
aux sondages qui expriment encore une
majorité d'opinions de sympathie pour le
mouvement est ce que vous attendez ce
que vous espérez que l'opinion bascule
et a estimé que le comédien françois
berléand dit plus la vérité que les
sondages quand il dit va alléger les
journées commencent à me faire chier
j'ai pas vu les derniers sondages donc
je ne sais pas comment les questions
sont posées
mais si la question c'est est ce que
vous comprenez le malaise des gens si
vous souhaitez en juger sur les 50 pour
mêler gilet jaune c'est beaucoup de
choses différentes moi je trouve que
j'en vois beaucoup d gilet jaune
d'abord les gilet jaune ça n'existe pas
vraiment au sens où à chaque fois que
quelqu'un a dit qu'il allait où elle
allait être le porte parole du mouvement
des gilet jaune
la base a dit il n'y a pas de porte
parole on est différent portent pas tous
les mêmes revendications mais moi je
reçois des délégations très
régulièrement
en général lorsque je me déplace en
province où lorsque j'accompagne le
président de la république
les gens que je vois ne sont pas
violents sont des gens avec lesquels on
a des discussions politiques de fond sur
l'exemplarité des dirigeants sur les
impôts sur des sujets sur lesquels on
est d'accord ou pas d'accord mais les
gilet jaune ça n'est pas la
manifestation des casseurs ça n'est pas
vraiment retombée depuis trois mois des
manifestations tous les samedis des
ronds points qui sont occupés des
phénomènes qui qui demeure et en trois
mois malgré les annonces des ménages
macron par exemple des 10 milliards
d'euros
la situation elle reste comme arrêter ça
veut dire quoi il faut encore en faire
plus il faut annoncer d'autres nouvelles
mesures non mais on a vraiment de choses
qui sont différentes on a des gens qui
se sont exprimés dans les médias et sur
les routes des gens qui se sont exprimés
dans les médias et sur les ronds points
en novembre et en décembre et on a
maintenant beaucoup d'expression dans le
cadre du grand débat dans les rues
on dans les contributions et c est donc
clairement l'expression est en train de
se structurer pour devenir des
propositions ou des prises à partie mais
dans un cadre plus dans un cadre qui est
en train de se mettre en place et après
on a de la violence les ronds points on
en a de moins en moins des ronds points
qui seront occupés on a des gens qui se
sont rencontrés sur les ronds-points et
qui continue à dialoguer ensemble ce que
j'ai vu par exemple
en bourgogne la semaine dernière sont
des gens qui se sont rencontrés sur un
rond-point qui n'y sont plus et qui
continue à dialoguer par ce qu'ils sont
en train de réfléchir politiquement à
quelle est leur proposition à côté de ça
on a quelques centaines quelques
milliers de personnes qui sont violentes
et c'est cette violence qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à arrêter mais ça n'est pas les
gilles et jo de la violence
battu sur le grand débat est ce que ce
n'est pas finalement une campagne
déguisée on à la proche des élections
européennes et l'opposition dénonce une
sorte de macron choqué ce que vous
répondez à ces accusations
je réponds que l'opposition dénonçait le
fait que le président ne s'adressait pas
aux français dans la période précédente
le fait que le président dialogue avec
les français aujourd'hui là on a le
président hariri
on assimile réunions locales qui sont
enregistrés sur la plateforme 2500 qui
ont eu lieu à peu près 3500 qui vont
avoir lieu le président enfer moyenne
une par semaine les membres de
l'exécutif participe à quelques unités
donc l'immense masse des réunions et
c'est normal et c'est très bien se fait
sans présidence en premier ministre
ministre très souvent sans parlementaire
public après les heures où l'activité
s'est pas une accusation fondée c'est le
président va au contact des français
quand ils voient des maires c'est un
contact républicain il y a des maires
qui le soutiennent et des mères qui ne
le soutiennent pas et dans les réunions
publiques dans lesquelles il est allé il
y avait des gens qui étaient d'accord
avec lui et des gens qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui quand c'était dans la
drôme
il y avait quelques personnes dans la
salle de plusieurs personnes qui
portaient des gilets jaunes ya eu un
dialogue c'était un dialogue sans
complaisance c'est normal que le
président parle aux français on lui a
reproché dans la période précédente de
ne pas l'avoir fait vraiment est-ce que
c'est grâce à ce grand débat est
justement à toutes ces heures où on le
voit
discutez avec les français qui leur
montrent dans l'opinion selon vous on
voit que les sondages sont sont
meilleures qu'il ya quelques semaines
pour moi il ya à la fois de l'intérêt
pour le débat et une inquiétude sur la
suite
je ne sais pas interpréter la remontée
dans les sondages mais moi ce que
j'entends ce que je vois les discussions
je peux avoir avec les uns les autres
les gens ont envie de parler politique
donc je pense que le débat ça répond à
une demande assez profonde et c'est
intéressant de voir que dans des
réunions très locale ce ne sont pas les
sujets locaux qui sont abordés sont
vraiment des sujets nationaux et plus
l'inquiétude c'est à quel point le
message les préoccupations les la colère
les interpellations vont être entendue
comment est ce qu'on saura transformer
tout ce que nous entendons en
propositions d'actions et en actions est
un programme de gouvernement un grand
scepticisme sur ce que vous allez faire
de quiétude en tout cas oui douleur de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on va
transformer tout ça en action alors il
ça me paraît aussi à le voir à le savoir
on a mis parcours et sa voix on est à
mi-chemin du grand débat risque on peut
espérer une espèce de rapport d'étape
comme ça
rapport d'étape mais l'embargo on vous
écoute je vais répondre d'abord à vos
questions et inquiétudes et arrivera un
rapport d'étape je suis pas je dis
scepticisme inquiétudes et le président
c'est pas mal exprimée dans pas mal de
réunions dans lesquelles il était dans
lesquelles il a dit ça sera un acte 2 ce
sera un nouveau moment du mandat et même
au delà ce sera une réinvention d'une
nouvelle forme de démocratie il y aura
des mesures fortes et puissantes
on n'en est pas encore au contenu on est
à peu près à la moitié du débat à moi a
eu lieu il reste une deuxième moitié je
vais y revenir
donc c'est vraiment prématuré de dire
bah ça y est on a tous décidé toute
façon on savait déjà avant ce qu'on
allait faire c'est pas vrai on le tabac
retour des demandes
après il ya des sujets qui reviennent y
être jugé au tour de la justice fiscale
on sent que y ça serait bien qu'on
puisse apporter une réponse il ya des
sujets autour de la manière dont les
dirigeants interagissent avec les
citoyens que ce soit les députés que ce
soit les membres du gouvernement
l'exécutif
moi je pense que c'est un sujet sur
lequel il faudra qu'on apporte des
réponses
il y à la transition écologique j'y
tiens on en parlera j'imagine en
deuxième partie mais tu as fait a
toujours une demande qu'on avance après
il est question de savoir comment on
fait sur qui ça doit tomber commence à
sa place donc il ya beaucoup de sujets
qui sont sur la table qui sont
d'ailleurs les essentiellement les
quatre thèmes qui ont été mis au débat
il y aura une réponse est ce qu'il ya
une injustice fiscale dans notre pays
selon vous est ce que je réponds un
rapport d'étape d'abord ou es ce que
vous avez pas encore parce que d'abord
on a passé pas mal de temps à travailler
avec les garants pour savoir comment
est-ce qu'on allait pouvoir analyser
toute cette matière on essaiera de
pouvoir faire une première restitution
quand on créera les conférences
régionales citoyenne qui auront lieu en
mars et qui avec des citoyens tirés au
sort une par région donc 13 en métropole
et 5 en outre-mer une dédiée aux jeunes
en plus son conte aura dix neuf
conférences elles auront lieu en mars
et là je pense qu'on les alimentera avec
une première matière issue des débats et
des contributions mais pas avant vous
parliez de la justice fiscale de
l'écologie notamment vous n'avez pas
d'immigration un thème qui a failli un
moment être l un des thèmes du grand
débat qu'est ce que ça veut dire
finalement quand on parle de libération
c'est interdit par les français ou les
français m - ce thème en avant que ce
qu'on aurait pu le croire
d'abord c'est toujours dedans parce que
si vous regardez les quatre
questionnaire dans le questionnaire qui
parle de démocratie et de citoyenneté il
y à des questions sur l'immigration est
par ailleurs dans la lettre du président
il y a clairement des questions sur
l'immigration
ce ne sont pas les sujets que moi
j'entends le plus mais
je suis allé dans une dizaine ou une
quinzaine de réunions donc c'est pas non
plus un échantillon représentatif
on verra si c'est très fortement
exprimée dans les contributions si on
regarde en masse les contributions qui
sont sur le site
on a à peu près 800 mille contribution
un peu plus de 200 milles aux questions
dites ouvertes et le reste sur les
questions rapides c'est d'abord la
fiscalité est ensuite l'écologie qui
ressortent comme les thèmes prioritaires
donc les sujets démocratie et
citoyenneté à l intérieur immigration
arrive assez bas en volumes
justement sur la question de la
fiscalité et de l'écologie quel est le
devenir de la taxe carbone vous êtes en
charge de l'écologie de la transition
écologique et solidaire est ce que vous
êtes favorable à un retour de cette taxe
carbone alors moi je suis favorable à
deux choses la première c'est que il ya
un retour de la taxe carbone dans le
débat c'est à dire que cette question
soit rediscuté c'est une question
politique est ce qu'il faut faire une
taxe carbone oui non c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'on dont on
débatte sérieusement officier en france
on vous sent je vais répondre je veux
répondants 30 secondes ma deuxième
réponse est que il faut financer la
transition écologique moi je plaiderai
très fortement avec françois de rugy
avec bruno poirson pour qu'on ait les
moyens de financer la transition
écologique il faut de l'argent public
il faut aussi de l'argent privé après
que ça passe par un mécanisme taxe
carbone et dans ce cas-là cette taxe
carbone il faut qu'on soit clair sur son
affectation
il faut que cette taxe carbone finances
le dans son intégralité la transition
écologique ou qu'on trouve d'autres
mécanismes fiscaux incitatifs ça je
trouve que la question est ouverte mais
en revanche on a besoin de ressources
pour financer la transition écologique
elle est devant nous
remaniée sur votre souhait mon souhait
c'est qu'on autorise de financement et
c'est important cette transition
écologique alors a besoin
d'investissements pour moi la taxe
carbone est possible si elle est
acceptée par tous elle ne peut être
acceptée que si elle est intégralement
utilisés pour cette transition
écologique
après il ya d'autres manières de faire
quelle taxe spécifique vient
voici un financement soit une taxe
fléché soit un financement accepté
collectivement est ce qu'on en a pas un
peu assez des ballons d'essai là qui
sont lancés par le gouvernement par
différents ministres pas vous mais là
ces derniers temps je pense notamment à
gérald darmanin ou d'autres on nous a
parlé d'un référendum éventuellement le
26 mai on nous a parlé de taxer les
niches fiscales ce qui est un peu
paradoxal mais finalement le chef de
l'état ne seraient pas d'accord et on
dire une forme de confusion qui s'est
installée vous ne trouvez pas pour moi
ce qui est important c'est ce qui
remonte du débat donc chaque ministre a
des convictions et c'est normal et vous
avez interrogé aussi sur les convictions
des uns des autres et vous me demandez
ce que je veux faire sur l'écologie et
c'est normal mais on siffle pas la fin
de la partie avant qu'elle soit jouée
la partie n'est pas jouée les
contributions ne sont pas fini on a
encore plein de réunions qui vont se
tenir on va avoir les conférences en
région et donc l'important est
clairement acté très gore ya rien a fait
une très large majorité
il est favorable toutes les études
d'opinion le montrent est ce que faire
un référendum serait une bonne idée
une bonne idée au cours de l'année 2019
par exemple mais ça dépend sur quoi en
fait pour moi la question ce n'est pas
tellement l'objet référendum
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on a
envie de soumettre au référendum je
voudrais vous répondre un peu plus en
amont puisque nous le dise carbone c'est
ce que 7 des sujets qui peuvent être
soumis au référendum bayer un petit peu
original tout peut être soumis au
référendum où mon point c'est de vous
dire on est pour l'instant dans une
démocratie représentative très classique
dans laquelle on a des élections et sauf
cas vraiment particulier entre deux
élections c'est le parlement qui décide
moi je crois qu'il faut qu'on trouve une
manière de s'adresser aux citoyens plus
régulièrement
est ce que c'est d'autant référendum
pourquoi pas est ce que c'est en
inventant quelque chose que les maires
ont inventé depuis déjà très longtemps
c'est à dire une juxtaposition de
travail directement avec des citoyens et
avec les élus évidemment c'est plus
facile à faire dans une mer
dans une commune qui à quelques milliers
d'habitants qu'à l'échelle de la france
mais ça marche bien quand vous avez le
conseil municipal d'un côté un conseil
citoyen de l'autre donc pour moi la
question est plus ouverte de savoir
comment est-ce qu'on mélange de la
démocratie représentative et de la
démocratie directe et le référendum
c'est une manière très forte de le faire
il faut choisir le bon sujet il faut que
ce soient des sujets sur lesquels la
décision à suffisent à le dossier a
suffisamment mûri pour que la décision
puisse être simple et que les avantages
et inconvénients puisse être compris de
tous
dernier exemple de référendum qu'on a
c'est le break site on peut pas dire que
ça allait très bien marché donc c'est
pas forcément surtout et pour moi la
question d autant qu on met au
référendum que le référendum y compris
mettre des projets de loi donc des
choses qu'ils ne soient pas forcément
constitutionnelle ce qui marquerait ce
qui classe ce qui créerait un précédent
ça vous pouvez y est favorable je suis
favorable à ce qu'on invente entre g en
nouveau en france avec plus de
démocratie directe je veux juste pas
rentrer tout de suite dans que soumettre
au référendum et est-ce que plus de
démocratie directe c'est forcément du
référendum ou est-ce que ça peut être
autre chose d'encore plus de démocratie
directe une meilleure association des
citoyens en cours de mandat sous des
formes à inventer en préservant la
démocratie en préservant la démocratie
représentative et d'une dernière
question madame bardot est ce qu'on peut
faire justement ce bilan d'étape combien
de français ont participé au grand débat
jusqu'ici combien de débats le président
va animer jusqu'à la mi mars est ce que
vous pouvez nous répondre à ces
questions donc combien de
réunions locales je vous dis 6000
réunion programmée ça nous dit pas
combien de français ont participé à des
réunions locales parce qu'on a des
réunions avec 300 400 500 personnes et
pas que quand il ya le président j'étais
à la mairie du 15e arrondissement à
paris il ya quelques temps et c'était
une réunion dans laquelle il y avait 500
personnes dans deux salles et 200
personnes qui n'ont pas pu rentrer on a
aussi des réunions petite moyenne dans
lesquelles il ya dix vingt trente
quarante personnes et c'est bien aussi
donc difficile de dire combien de
personnes ont participé à des réunions
1,6 million de personnes qui se sont
connectés sur le site internet
trois cent mille qui ripostaient une
contribution 800000 contribution parce
qu'on peut poster une contribution sur
plusieurs thèmes
le président a participé à une dizaine
de réunions à peu près c'est lors de
grandes il va continuer combien encore
il a annoncé qu'il continuait je n'ai
pas de chiffres et c'est lui qui
maîtrise son agenda une par semaine en
tous les cas voilà merci beaucoup c'est
la suite d'auditions publiques
maintenant avec les deux parlementaires
font leur entrée sur le plateau
avec nous donc laurent saison et
rossignol bonsoir sénatrice socialiste
de l'oise est à vos côtés robert et d'un
député et l'air de l'essonne
bonsoir à tulle et les deux mesures
aident à vous avez participé d'ailleurs
à un grand débat avec avec des
personnalités importantes avec des
personnalités importantes avec le
présent de l'arrivée des avec le premier
ministre censé participer à des grands
débats pas aussi prestigieux comme si
peu mais quand même ils m'ont si vous
participez une question d'un internaute
du figaro avant de vous donner la parole
il nous demande le budget du ministère
de l'écologie ces 40 milliards et il
prétend qu'il y en a que 10 qui servent
vraiment l'écologiste ce sera l'ordre de
grandeur
non non c'est plus que ça il ya une
dizaine de milliards juste sur la partie
transition énergétique des énergies
renouvelables
le budget du ministère ça doit être 34
milliards et la majeure partie des 34
milliards va directement des politiques
environnement a lieu avec l'objet de
votre ministre la sortie du rang social
c'est à moi je voulais vous poser une
question est ce que vous êtes prêts à
l'issue du grand débat et peut-être même
dès maintenant à changer de politique
je vous explique pourquoi je vous pose
cette question et je vais prendre pour
cela 3 3 sujets le premier c'est la
réforme de la justice la réforme de la
justice
on en parle dans les assemblées gd gilet
jaune
j'ai les citoyens particulier cet après
midi avait un débat sur l'égalité femmes
hommes organisent dans le cadre du grand
débat toutes les questions qu'on pose et
les femmes qui étaient présentes
concernait la justice la proximité de la
justice or la réforme de la justice
mais contre elle la totalité des
professions judiciaires ce qui est assez
exceptionnel était pas arrivé depuis
nicolas sarkozy ce mémoire est bonne et
aussi les justiciables et demain il va
revenir au sénat cette réforme alors que
tout le monde
tout le monde est contre vous êtes vous
pensez que vous avez raison contre tout
le monde
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à suspendre
deuxième sujet de la politique du
logement est ce que vous êtes prêts à
revenir sur ce que vous ayez fait je
vous donner un exemple dans mon
département michel grossiord le site et
un insensé loi je crois que vous
connaissez un peu aussi dans l'oise les
bailleurs sociaux ou expliqué il ya
quelques jours qu'en 2019 on allait
construire deux fois moins de logements
sociaux et réhabi
c'est deux fois moins de logements
sociaux qu'en 2018 on en verra les
effets dans deux ou trois ans de ces
noms construction de logements est ce
que vous êtes prêts à rendre
d'un certain point de vue aux bailleurs
sociaux les réserves que vous leur avez
ponctionner voilà les deux sujets déjà
qu'ils sont assez bien ce qu'elle
voulait parler et puis le troisième
c'est quand même ce qui fait aussi d'un
l'unanimité contre vous aux particuliers
au sénat c'est la privatisation des dp
parce que je partage avec vous je vous
écoute et un instant l'idée que les
gilet jaune c'est très varié et les gens
qui les soutiennent aussi sont variés
unir les jd jaune c'est un peu comme
dire les américains ça veut pas dire
grand chose mais quand même il ya des
points communs et dans ses points
communs
il ya une résistance à
l'ultralibéralisme sas est présent à peu
près chez tous les gilets jaunes à leur
réponse est donc la privatisation adp
c'est vraiment du dogmatisme libéral
puisque vous êtes arrivé au sénat à
faire l'unanimité droite gauche
elle est enlevée tous les groupes contre
la privatisation adp je pense que nous
avons raison de vous mettre en garde
concept la manière dont aujourd'hui vous
dilapidez certain point de vue des
outils publics indispensables à eur3
réformes contestées pour vous demander
de changer de politique
alors sur la question générale est ce
qu'on est prêt à changer
oui je crois qu'on est prêt à changer de
à prendre en compte la parole des
français telle qu'elle va s'exprimer
dans ce débat et nous sommes rentrés
aussi avec une question très ouverte sur
le service public de proximité comment
est ce qu'on fait pour répondre à un
besoin légitime de service public de
proximité
ensuite sur vos questions particulières
sachant que je ne suis pas une
spécialiste de ces trois réformes pour
la privatisation de la dp je crois que
la question elle est autant dans le
comment que dans la justification
la justification elle est simplement lié
au fait qu'à un moment on a besoin de
concentrer les investissements publics
dans des investissements qui sont des
investissements de rupture qui nous
permettront de développer l'économie de
main et qu'on n'a pas forcément intérêt
à garder des rentes dans des entreprises
qui sont matures
en revanche on est prêt à tirer les
leçons des privatisations dite sèche
précédentes je pense aux sociétés
autoroutières pour que dans la manière
de faire dans le cahier des charges dans
les obligations qu'on imposera aux
futurs opérateurs dans la capacité à
garder la main ou à la reprendre
on soit plus armé que ce qu'on a pu être
dans les épisodes précédents sur le
logement
il me semble que la question à laquelle
on a répondu dans la période précédente
c'était aussi toutes ces réserves des
opérateurs qui n'étaient pas utilisés et
du coup il faut qu'on trouve le bon
équilibre entre l'utilisation de
réserves qui permet d'activer et la
capacité de ces opérateurs à continuer à
construire on a toujours un objectif de
construction de logements enfin sur la
réforme de la justice de ce que je
comprends de ce sujet donc je le redis
je ne suis pas une spécialiste
on cherche plus à spécialiser par
compétences les tribunaux d'instance car
éloigner le tribunal du justiciable je
crois que c'est dans cet esprit qu'on
est prêt à continuer à travailler
robert et da manha même l'illustrent
avant de venir aux questions fiscales
devraient revenir sur grand débat le
grand débat vous l'avais dit en france
en ce moment c'est un succès auprès des
français qui s'en emparent au plus près
du terrain sans président de la
république son premier ministre son
ministre et qui effectivement essaye de
faire vivre des propositions concrètes
qui émane de leur vie quotidienne
et puis à côté de ce grand débat il ya
le grand meeting national des manuels
macron j'en ai assisté
1 la semaine dernière bassiste et un
meeting un meeting électoral ou en fait
emmanuel macron et c'est bien là qu'on
comprend qu'il ne changera pas de
politique ne passe son temps à justifier
les mesures qu'il a prises depuis un an
et demi à la tête de l'état a justifié
le cap économique qu'il s'est fixé et ne
corrigé qu'à la marge en réalité les
dispositifs sur lesquelles on les
interpelle
et ça c'est très grave parce que non
seulement emmanuel macron dans ces
réunions en filigrane se présente comme
moi ou le chaos et ça c'est très grave
parce que nous aurons le chaos
si emmanuel macron continue d'annihiler
toute opposition et toute contradiction
mais la question je voudrais vous poser
c'est que vous êtes l'incarnation de ce
nouveau monde emmanuel macron vous venez
du monde de l'entreprise et emmanuel
macron dans cette campagne qu'il mène
auprès des français dans ce grand débat
on a l'impression qu'il n'a qu'une
obsession c'est sa réélection est-ce que
c'est moderne ça de ne vouloir que sa
réélection est pas le bien-être des
français
alors vous comprendrez que je partage
pas ce point de vue je vais essayer de
vous expliquer pourquoi
d'abord au contraire moi j'entends un
président assez ouvert sur la majeure
partie des sujets je vais prendre
l'exemple emblématique des 80 km heure
il a quand même dit l'a dit dans la
drôme que peut-être que il fallait qu'on
revoie notamment une application
beaucoup plus localisées que ça ne soit
plus normes france entière mais qu'on
puisse rediscuter au plus près des
territoires département par département
de la manière dont on applique ça donc
pour un sujet qui était présenté comme
un sujet politique extrêmement verser le
fondement de la politique mais là qui
compte c'est qu'on a entendu le chef de
l'état son premier ministre le ministre
d'économie dire encore ce week-end les
réformes annoncées vont avoir lieu c'est
un peu l'interpellation
j'avais à vous dire où les en ce moment
j'avais l'ex temps dans l'assemblée dans
le scénar vous déroulé pendant que
pendant que les français pendant les
travaux le théâtre des régulations
continue pas vraiment il ya beaucoup de
textes qu'on a arrêté ou retarder la
réforme institutionnelle par exemple la
réforme constitutionnelle des
institutions et c'est normal on peut pas
discuter d'une réforme constitutionnelle
en même temps qu'on discute de la
démocratie et de la citoyenneté
elle a été elle a été reportée
la loi sur les mobilités qui devait
passer tout de suite les transports
comment est-ce qu'on revoie les
transports comment est-ce qu'on organise
mieux les choses pour que des transports
de proximité puissent se mettre en place
cette loi elle est aussi un peu décalé
dans son calendrier
pour que les conclusions du grand débat
arrive au bon moment au contraire on a
plutôt regardé sujet par sujet ce qui
était vraiment touchée par le débat pour
lesquelles on a plutôt décidé de décaler
après il ya des textes qui avait été
dopé par sa réélection décale les
réformes importantes mais vous pourrez
part à la fois me dire vous décalez
enfin vous déroulez ou voûté calais il
est préoccupé donc ils justifient les
préoccupent et donc ils avancent où ils
avancent pas il ya un moment vous pouvez
m'appeler nous dire qu'on est incohérent
la réforme constitutionnelle le
gouvernement n'était pas prêt et le
climat était quand même pas favorable a
déroulé une réforme constitutionnelle
mais n'empêche que l'annoncé en janvier
on est presque défunt on l'attend la loi
sur la mobilité des français l'attendent
alors j'imagine que vous allez leur dire
que vous allez l'enrichira par le grand
débat c'est pas les égorger sur
aujourd'hui la loi sur la mobilité des
moyens qui sont donnés il ya un manque
de moyens sur cette loi
peut-être que d'ici le grand débat vous
avez trouvé les moyens de la loi mais
moi sur les sur ce dont on vous a parlé
et je partage un peu le point de vue de
mon voisin sur l'objet du grand débat
parce que j'ai le sentiment que le
président de la république j'en suis
désolé pour vous personnellement qu est
très investi dans le grand débat est en
train d'asphyxier le grand débat ils
n'apprennent d'étouffer ce grand débat
ce train de devenir le grand oral
on a l'impression que le présent la
république passe le grand oral toutes
les semaines devant les français et
haskell mieux qu'à menacer clyde est
filmé et retransmis le don qu'il aurait
pas lui reprocher de fonds d'ajustement
à michel l'instant le temps vous avez
c'est bien qu'il fasse une performance
mais ce dont les français ont besoin
aujourd'hui c'est pas d'un président qui
sait faire des performances quasi
sportive ce débat la manière dont elles
se contentent dans ce débat c'est devenu
une permanence performances sportives
on en est content c'est pas exactement
le sujet qui est posé aujourd'hui dans
le pays
bon alors je vais essayer de répondre
rapidement mais je vais quand même
essayer de répondre d'abord la
participation du président elle a
commencé à partir d'un engagement de
voir les maires parce que je vous
rappelle que les premières réunions que
le président organise et c'était des
réunions avec les maires et cette
promesse avait été faite même avant le
lancement du débat ce que la critique
précédente était pas assez de
considération pour les élus locaux les
élus de terrain et donc il s'était
engagé à aller en région voir les maires
et c'est ce qu'il a commencé à faire
forcément les mêmes
plein de questions des questions liées à
l'exercice du mandat de maire autour
d'eux des normes des dotations etc et
des questions plus citoyenne et donc les
deux exercices se sont rencontrés après
il a été critiqué sur le mode y voit des
mers n'y voit pas des vrais citoyens
entre guillemets même si les maires de
petites communes et les vrais citoyens
c'est pas forcément extrêmement
différent mais il voyait les maires sk
zytek de laurent wauquiez
il a participé à quelques réunions en
particulier celles dans la drôme des
réunions ouvertes au public
progressivement les formats vont être
modifiés et encore une fois
certes ces réunions sont très
médiatisées mais pendant ce temps là il
ya plein de réunions partout avec des
gens qui réfléchissent donc il ya d'un
côté un exercice où le président
retourne au contact et de l'autre un
exercice de débats et de consultation
après sur l'évolution de la politique
le président a été élu sur une vision et
sur un programme économique et il est
aussi interpellé sur ses choix et donc
il explique ses choix mais je voudrais
vous redire que je sens une volonté très
forte de prendre en considération ce qui
sortira du débat et pour aller peut-être
sur un sujet qui est un sujet polémique
qui élit sf
il a été dit le président l'a dit le
gouvernement l'a dit qu'on ne
reviendrait pas sur l'objet et isf
mais le président a aussi dit premier
ministre aussi que la question de la
justice fiscale était mise au débat et
que peut-être que ce sera une autre
réponse qui sera apporté à la même
question de la justice fiscale donc il
faut séparer la justification de
certaines décisions et la capacité à
entendre des messages que peut-être on
n'entendait pas suffisamment dans la
période précédente et qui ont été
portées très fortement vigoureusement
parfois par les gilets jaunes en bout de
course
vous nous dites que effectivement il
faut faire payer plus les hauts revenus
je vous dis que l'accusation la question
de la justice fiscale n'a été posée moi
j'ai pris une position personnelle qui
est à dire que je pensais que ça pouvait
avoir du sens de rajouter une tranche à
l'impôt sur le revenu ou en tout cas
qu'on pouvait se demander comment est-ce
que l'impôt sur le revenu pourrait
contribuer plus à la justice fiscale
c'est une position personnelle
ça n'est pas un ballon d'essai du
gouvernement pour répondre à la question
précédente
c'est vraiment ce que je pense mais
au-delà de ce que je pense qui n'est pas
très intéressant c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi ce qui se passe
dire dans le débat on accepte le fait
que peut-être qu'il faudra répondre sur
cette question c'est vrai que je suis
d'accord avec vous sur une chose madame
aimiez c'est que le grand débat national
il ne vous exonère pas de continuer
l'action au service des français
et malheureusement c'est pas con ce
qu'on constate parce que l'origine de
cette crise des gilets jaunes c'est
d'une crise du pouvoir d'achat et de la
fiscalité et notamment une crise de ces
classes moyennes qui paye toujours plus
d'impôts de taxes de cotisation et qui
finalement estime ne pas avoir assez en
retour notamment en termes de protection
sociale une protection sociale qui leur
bénéficie de moins en moins et c'est une
réforme totale du système fiscal il faut
effectivement mené au delà d'une
position personnelle de vous ou de
monsieur darmanin ou du président de la
république il faut remettre à plat de ce
système fiscal c'est pourquoi il faut le
remettre à plat parce que la cour des
comptes est venu nous expliquer la
semaine dernière devant la
représentation nationale que la france
était dans le rouge qu'elle explosait
tous les compteurs du déficit de la
dette et plus de dettes plus de déficits
c'est de marc fragiliser les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes parce
que la première récession venue notre
pays ne pourra pas faire face
il ne peut pas faire face et pour que
non on n'est pas tous d'accord parce que
l engagement du président de la
république et l'action qui doit
continuer c'est la baisse du déficit
public
la baisse des dépenses publiques pour
baisser les impôts en particulier des
classes populaires des classes moyennes
et malheureusement ce que l'on constate
c'est un dérapage de nos finances
publiques plus 44 milliards de dépenses
publiques depuis le début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron c'est plus que la
dépense publique qui s'accroissait sous
le mandat de monsieur hollande est donc
la règle c'est qu'aujourd'hui si les
réformes structurelles ne sont pas
faites pour améliorer la vie quotidienne
des français il n'y a pas de baisse de
la dépense publique
il n'y a pas de baisse des impôts revue
vous dites vous même que vous voulez
rajouter des tranches à l'impôt sur le
revenu supprimer des niches fiscales
avec monsieur darmana en réalité ça
s'appelle augmenter les impôts et ce
sont les classes moyennes qui seront les
premières touchées
moi je préfère le débat fiscal ce soir
mais je voulais revient sur une phrase
que vous venez de prononcer et qui à mon
sens c'est un des malentendus qui
explique la difficulté de la situation à
laquelle nous sommes collective
vous avez dit le président du mcs roi
était nu sur une vision et un programme
économique
non il a été élu pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
j'ai voté mais macron deuxième tour
d'élection présidentielle
malgré les grandes inquiétudes que
j'avais sur son programme économique et
social mais parce que je pensais que
c'était important de faire barrage à
l'extrême droite bruno la même chose
demain puisqu'il ya des sondages l'a
récemment de marianne probablement donc
vous n'êtes pas sur cette si le dire le
le dire aujourd'hui oui je leur ferais
la même chose sauf que j'ai fait j'ai
pas douter et même je les fais faire en
non mais ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que le malentendu il est terrible
vous faites d'un certain point de vue la
même erreur que ça qu'à effet jacques
chirac en 2002 c'est de croire que quand
on est élu au second tour pour faire
barrage au front national on peut
dérouler derrière toute la politique en
l'occurrence en ce qui vous concerne
libéral que vous déroulez alors c'est
pas ça qu'est françois voulu et vous ne
cessez de répéter à longueur de temps
nous avons été élus pour faire cette
politique là non vous avez été vus pour
faire barrage au fn
et ce qui nous inquiète c'est qu'on
pense que l'on main ou crainte la
politique que vous menez ne conduisent à
renforcer encore davantage une
opposition d'extrême droite est affaire
de l'extrême droite la seule alternative
et je sais bien que c'est un petit
calcul politique pour 2022 venir des
gens comme moi michel grossin ne posais
la question est alors vous ferez quoi au
deuxième tour entre le front national et
même macron est bien très probablement
j'y retournerai la corde au cou et je
remettrai mon bulletin emmanuel macron
et l'idée que vous pensez à ça que vous
calculer ça et que vous miser là dessus
est extrêmement dévastatrice pour le
climat du pays et en plus très risqué
sur le résultat de 2022 parce que il
n'est pas dit qu'une majorité de gens
qui passent comme moi et si on faisait
ça il se serait pas lancé dans cette
opération de consultation est débat
général sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets assez fort et qui sont des sujets
au coeur du débat citoyen
d'une certaine manière la crise des îles
et joe nous a amené à cette consultation
dont il n'y a pas vraiment d'équivalent
sous la vème république et qui amènera à
modifier infléchir enrichir je sais pas
quel est le bon mot la trajectoire de
réforme du goût
moment et ce sera un nouvel acte du
gouvernement et du quinquennat donc
c'est bien la preuve que le président a
accepté l'idée de retourner au contact
de d'écouter la parole des français est
un calcul politique oui je ne suis pas
dans ce calcul et du coup moi je vous
envoie quand je vois leurs choses et
l'extrême droite pour être assuré d'être
réélu c'est ce que je comprends pas ce
que vous répondre ça détruire tout ce
qui est entre l'extrême droite et
emmanuel macron et en cette clique de
fait toutes les façons il ya pas que
nous irons sans intermédiaire les médias
les médias ont des corps intermédiaires
tous les contre-pouvoirs mis en cause
depuis juin 2010 est en bermuda non
c'est ce que j'évoquais quand je disais
qu emmanuel macron essayer de se penser
en lui ou le chaos et ce sera le chaos
pour la france parce que emmanuel macron
ne sera pas l'alternative à emmanuel
macron est en réalité il faut demain
qu'ils respectent davantage les
oppositions c'était un premier pas avec
la loi casseurs qui vient la loi
anti-casseurs plutôt qu'il vient du
sénat qui était proposée par bruno
retailleau et qui a été voté quasiment
dans les mêmes termes à l'assemblée
nationale est d'ailleurs si j'avais une
question sur cela c'est est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à la soutenir jusqu'au bout
parce qu'on se dit que certains de la
majorité et les rues m voudrait
détricoter ce texte
finalement on a l'impression qu'ils
n'ont pas tiré les enseignements de la
montée de violence que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure et qui nous inquiète tous
et la réalité c'est que vous devez
davantage écouter l'opposition les
bonnes propositions celles qui
permettront de pacifier la vie des
français est d'améliorer la vie des
français actifs
je dirai juste une chose qui est gg j'ai
défendu une loi à l'assemblée nationale
il ya environ trois semaines un mois sur
un sujet dans mon ministère car
transition écologique et on est arrivé
un vote en première lecture dans lequel
j'ai eu zéro vote négatif donc des votes
pour de la majorité des abstentions de
ceux qui ne sont pas dans la majorité
donc moi je suis assez convaincu que le
travail parlementaire au plus près en
regardant sujet par sujet amendement par
amendement peut mener un consensus c'est
que c'est mieux d'aller jusqu'au bout de
cette logique sur la loi évidemment
c'était une loi plus techniques sur la
biodiversité on parle pas tout à fait la
même chose sur la loi dite anti casseurs
le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités elle a été examinée par
le sénat elle a été votée à l'assemblée
nationale on cherche le bon équilibre
c'est une loi importante avec des sujets
graves parce que ce sont des sujets qui
mettent en cause les libertés publiques
donc on cherche vraiment le meilleur
équilibre possible entre la capacité à
maintenir l'ordre public que vous aimez
cette ce texte a été adopté par la quasi
totalité moins 50 des députés de la
république en marche bon il faut le
calcul politique répondait d'une phrase
est en soi c'est une race calcul
politique moi je fais pas la politique
du pire je suis pas rentré au
gouvernement pour ça j'essaye avec
sincérité d'animer ce débat auquel je
crois et je suis assez convaincu qu'on
sera capable d'écouter la parole des
français quand elle sera structuré voilà
pour cette partie échanges merci à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté le nerf de
l'audition publique ce soir face à
emmanuelle wargon que nous allons
interroger maintenant sur la transition
écologique
[Musique]
bonsoir président bush et aurier mancini
merci sarko comme chaque semaine une
question d'un internaute du figaro vous
avez dit il ya un instant effectivement
qu emmanuel macron qui tient le micro
pendant des heures ça lui donne une
présence médiatique impressionnante mais
est-ce qu'elle est déséquilibré du coup
par rapport aux autres partis est-ce
qu'il faut que csa remettre de l'ordre
interviennent et ce qu'il faut que les
médias comptabilise le temps de parole
du chef de l'état médias sont libres
donc je me prononcerai pas sur comment
est ce que les médias utilisent leur
temps de parole et après il ya ou leur
temps d'antenne ya un csa c'est son
métier il fera son métier ce sera très
bien pour viol après le départ de
nicolas hulot du gouvernement c'est l'un
de ses proches le député matthieu
orphelin qui a quitté le groupe la
république en marche la semaine dernière
est ce que ces départs sont
l'illustration du renoncement des
manuels macron à l'écologie moi je
regrette le départ de matthieu orphelin
je les dis en fait la transition
écologique
c'est un sujet qui est vertigineux dès
qu'on le regarde parce que l'urgence est
gigantesque et en plus cette urgence
elle a été dénoncée depuis maintenant
très longtemps tous les discours et
compris du président chirac
et pendant que cette urgence et dénoncer
on voit le réchauffement climatique qui
s'accélère donc l'ampleur de la tâche
est gigantesque
après face à cette ampleur moi je crois
que notre mission c'est d'agir d'agir le
plus vite possible plus fort possible et
que quand on a la possibilité d'être
dans l'action à l'hormadi en feu lundi
que les avancées sont insuffisantes
notamment sur les enjeux climatiques les
invités seront toujours insuffisante
c'est pas une raison pour pas se battre
bien sûr qu'on peut toujours faire plus
mais oui je dis que d'une certaine
manière
quand le combat manuel wargon qui avait
renoncé quand on voit que la production
d'électricité la part du nucléaire dans
la production d'électricité vous l'avez
décalé dix ans quand on voit que les
réacteurs nucléaires a que deux qui
seront fermés à sessenheim pendant le
quinquennat est ce que touche a
finalement c'est pas des renoncements on
peut parler du glyphosate on veut parler
de tous ces sujets sur tous les sujets
vous avez décaler la date
parlons des coûts tandis que ça
m'intéresse d'en parler il faut sortir
d'un système dans lequel on vote des
textes et après plus personne
s'intéresse à comment on applique les
textes et après quand on arrivait qu'on
essaye de mettre en oeuvre les décisions
on se rend compte que c'est plus
compliqué que ça je vais prendre
fessenheim pour commencer fessenheim
c'est le premier la première centrale
nucléaire non on va fermer les réacteurs
ça a été décidée il ya longtemps il ne
s'était rien passé ni avec edf ni sur le
territoire de fessenheim c'est ce
gouvernement
à son arrivée je voudrais saluer
l'action de mon prédécesseur sébastien
lecornu qui a commencé à regarder
précisément mais ça veut dire quoi
fermer fessenheim
comment est-ce qu'on négocie avec edf
comment est-ce qu'on bâtit un projet de
territoire ou comment est-ce qu'on
replace les personnes concernées comment
est-ce qu'on remet de l'activité
économique donc fessenheim on a signé le
projet de territoire avec françois de
rugy ya une semaine les deux réacteurs
ferme en mars 2020 et en juillet 2020 on
a obtenu un appel d'offres validé
exceptionnel validé par la commission
européenne pour remettre du
photovoltaïque uniquement dans le
département concerné edf s'engage pour
mettre en place un technocentre pour le
démantèlement est tout un projet avec
une vingtaine d'actions transfrontalière
on l'a mis dans traité d'aix la chapelle
et donc son statut est une chose y
finalement elles attendront même si les
centrales sont vétustes
je crois pas avoir dit elle attend dont
je vous explique on rend vraiment
possible matériellement possible est
réel une fermeture qui a été annoncé il
ya bien longtemps mais est on perdrait
meriaux d'ici 2035 ça devient du 20/02
seulement sous le sous le quinquennat
les autres attendront plus tard on se
demande quand même pourquoi vous
attendez aussi longtemps mais ça
s'anticipe tout ça
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie à laquelle vous faites
allusion
elle prévoit la trajectoire pour arriver
à 50% de nucléaire en 2035
oui dans la loi il y avait 2025 cet
horizon 2025 c'est même pas c'est même
pas techniquement possible aujourd'hui
donc on refait une trajectoire possible
est la grande différence entre cette
mandature ce gouvernement et les
précédents c'est con on travaille sujet
par sujet pour que ça se produise sinon
c'est trop facile de voter une date et
puis d'après laisser tomber et c'est à
dire ça aura lieu où ça n'aura pas lieu
mais toute façon ce sera les suivre une
opinion personnelle finalement le
nucléaire pour vous il a du bon puisque
j'ai vu que jamais la france l'an
dernier mais avait produit une
électricité aussi peu carbonée c'est
aussi l'un des objectifs de votre
ministère est ce que donc vous
considérez que les centrales nucléaires
les plus récents tu ne parles pas de
fessenheim ou les projets d'avenir je
pense à le p r ont une raison d'être sur
le territoire français moi je suis à
l'aise avec l'objectif que le
gouvernement s'est fixé d'aller à la
moitié de notre électricité produite à
partir de nucléaire en 2006 ça veut dire
que je considère que c'est légitime de
garder du nucléaire à hauteur d'environ
la moitié dans le mix énergétique en
on verra où en sont le reste des
énergies renouvelables si on sait aller
encore plus bas sachant que le nucléaire
al'avantage comme tout le monde c'est de
ne pas émettre de gaz à effet de serre
et que le nucléaire a plein
d'inconvénients dont la question de
savoir ce qu'on fait du des déchets
nucléaires et comment est-ce qu'on gère
le démantèlement il n'y a pas de sources
d'énergie parfaite et c'est le mix qui à
mon avis la bonne solution donc les
énergies renouvelables elles
représentent aujourd'hui 16% à 1 de la
consommation d'électricité en france
bruxelles a fixé un objectif 23 % en
2020 ce que vous pensez que la france
pourra atteindre cet objectif
on est sur une trajectoire ambitieuse on
met beaucoup d'argent sur les énergies
renouvelables sur le solaire
re sur l'éolien en particulier aussi sur
la méthanisation l'éolien je pense qu'on
a une vraie question d'acceptation
paysagère d'acceptation sur les
territoires je pense qu'il faut qu'on y
prenne garde et qu'on trouve la manière
de continuer à développer l'énergie
éolienne mais en comprenant les
préoccupations mais oui on a la capacité
installée
les technologies sont de plus en plus
mature et on a les financements qui vont
avouer que j'ai eu l'idée d'un échec
comme le prétend pourtant le député
démissionnaire du groupe majoritaire
monsieur mais le succès il va falloir
attendre combien de temps mais pour moi
c'est une bataille qui se gagne étape
par étape et après je voudrais je
voudrais prendre la transition agricoles
parce que pour moi c'est un sujet mais
ya pas de l'ex écologistes elle passe
depuis 18 mois soit elles ont rejoint le
groupe territoire et libertés soit
nicolas hulot est partie mathieu
orphelin maintenant vous n'avez plus +
d'écologistes finalement à vous à vos
côtés comment vous comment vous analyser
ça vous dit pas quand même que vous êtes
passé à côté du meilleur planète great
games je me dis qu'on a une ambition qui
est très forte pour laquelle on se bat
tous les jours et il reste des députés
qui viennent de l'écologie quant à
barbara pompili président de la
commission développement durable et puis
le ministre d'état en charge de la
transition écologique et solidaire
françois de rugy l' engagement
écologiste depuis longtemps mais contre
d'autres ministres à bercy par exemple
je voudrais juste finir sur
l'agriculture avant de parler merci
parce que c'est aussi un point important
ce qu'en fait c'est la même question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on passe de il
faudrait mais on sait pas comment faire
à ont fait la transition la transition
agricole elle nécessite d'avoir moins de
pesticides
elle nécessite de partager l'eau
différemment elle nécessite de mobiliser
beaucoup plus les agriculteurs pour
imaginer une agriculture plus durable
qui épuise - les sols bio étant une
solution mais pas que il ya aussi
d'autres formes d'agriculture durable ça
ça se fait en travaillant à partir de
solutions concrètes d'exemple donc ça se
fait avec les agriculteurs et
on a été beaucoup questionné sur
l'interdiction du glyphosate la france a
été celle qui a poussé l'europe pour
avoir une ré autorisation uniquement
pour cinq ans et pas pour 15 ans et on
s'est donné un objectif politique qui
n'a pas été mis dans la loi on nous l'a
reproché à l'époque de sortir du
glyphosate en trois ans et si on y
arrive a dit dans la drôme qu'en fait ce
n'était pas faisable un renoncement de
plus c'est pas un renoncement c'est un
objectif politique de sortir aussi vite
que possible un cadeau à la fnsea avant
le salon de l'agriculture est objectif
c'est d'aller à 100 % en trois ans si on
dit peut-être que ce sera 80 ou 85 ou
90% ce n'est pas un renoncement c'est
juste expliqué qu' il faut qu'on passe
les étapes les unes après les autres
l'important c'est qu'on en sortie ces
trois ans et demi moi je préfère un
gouvernement qui s'engage à sortir du
glyphosate
en trois ans on se donne l'objectif en
trois ans peut-être que ce sera trois
ans et demi peut être que ce sera quatre
ans mais on le fait versus toutes ces
normes qui sont votées un jour qui ne
sont jamais appliquées et cinq ans après
on regarde on se dit ban on ne savait
pas faire et on vote la norme d'après
c'est pas logique a life et nationale
juste avant sa mort agriculture c'est la
volonté d'arriver à trouver la solution
avec les agriculteurs et pas contre vous
changez pas l'agriculture sans les
agriculteurs ça ne marche pas ça
fonctionne pas
michel parler des divergences avec vers
6 heures vous avez notamment une
divergence avec bruno le maire sur la
vignette critères 1 c'est la vignette
pour les véhicules les moins polluants
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
mais il veut apposer sa dînette aux
véhicules diesel raisons pour soutenir
la filière pour préserver les emplois
vous y est hostile qui va gagner cet
arbitrage
le ministère de l'écologie on est tous
alignés françois de rugy elisabeth
bornes brune poirson et moi on dit tous
c'est une décision scientifique critères
rincer les véhicules les moins polluants
tout pole man confondues si on arrive à
démontrer que le diesel atteint les
critères pourquoi pas c'est par
débattent doctrine c'est un débat
scientifique
après le diesel on a vécu le diesel
guette donc c'est sûr que tout le monde
est un peu méfiant sur la capacité aux
fans le caractère polluant ou pas du
diesel le diesel en conditions de test
le diesel en conditions réelles de route
et c'est un débat qui se réglera avec
des experts et scientifiques vous
comprenez les inquiétudes du ministère
de l'économie autour des emplois de la
filière diesel bien sûr je comprends
tout à fait les inquiétudes économiques
du maire mais la politique écologique ça
doit pas être la variable d'ajustement
des politiques économiques la politique
celle écologique ça doit être une
ambition et après il faut qu'on arrive à
embarquer les filières économiques et
les filières social d'ailleurs parce que
derrière il ya des emplois et il ya
aussi des emplois à la clé dans les
voitures hybrides dans les voitures
électriques dans la transition même
langage que bruno le maire si je
comprends bien non on a les mêmes
préoccupations après c'est la manière
dont on y met cette question bien emploi
cette question de l'emploi et se pose
aussi puisque le sénat a repoussé d'un
an d'interdiction des couverts en
plastique avec le soutien du
gouvernement s'était encore bruno le
maire puisque ça a été votée dans la loi
pacte est ce que finalement on a
l'impression qu'au gouvernement il ya un
combat emplois contre écologie est ce
que l'emploi passe avant l'écologie
en fait on a vécu pendant assez
longtemps une opposition entre
l'économique et le social c'est à dire
est ce qu'il fallait faire plus tôt du
social ou plutôt de l'économique
maintenant on arrive à un moment où il
faut arriver à trouver l'équilibré entre
écologique économique et sociale c'est
pas facile à trouver mais le ministère
de l'écologie se défendra pour que
l'écologie ne soit pas la variable
d'ajustement de tout ça et après c'est
au cas par cas que ça c'est donc un
combat entre ministres ont bien complété
sûr de gagner le bras de fer
c'est un bras 30 ans avec des enjeux qui
sont légitimes des deux côtés après il
faut trouver la bonne résultante cité
des sujets ça c'est ça votre message à
bercy c'est de dire que l'écologie n'est
pas une variable d'ajustement
oui mais ça je les assume très bien ça
vous l'assumez donc c'est bien une
pierre dans le jardin de bercy je suis
désolé je veux pas vous mettre en
difficulté mais c'est ce qu'on essaie de
comprendre hier devant une pétition
également pour le climat plus de deux
millions de signatures c'est un recours
juridique finalement contre l'état pour
une action climatique c'est la première
fois ces inédits plus de deux millions
de signatures
comment vous réagissez face à ça quelle
est votre réponse finalement à cette
énorme mobilisation citoyenne
finalement je trouve ça plutôt bien
qu'on ait deux millions de personnes qui
disent il faut faire quelque chose pour
le climat
à montre que la volonté que l'écologie
ne soit pas la variable d'ajustement
c'est une volonté qui est partagé après
une question qui est posée à l'état pour
savoir si on n'agit assez vite et assez
fort donc ça ramène à la discussion
qu'on avait il ya beaucoup d'action qui
sont engagés on n'a pas parlé de la
rénovation du bâtiment par exemple sur
laquelle il ya des moyens la fois
publiques et privées
beaucoup d'offres la volonté de
simplifier de trouver la manière que
chacun puisse en bénéficier
donc c'est aussi une question
d'appréciation mais à un moment moi ce
qui me paraît très intéressant c'est
qu'on soit pas en opposition les
citoyens attendent en tout l'état mais
qu'on soit en travail en commun qu'est
ce qui doit être fait par la puissance
publique soit en financement soit en
interdiction qu'est ce qui peut et doit
être fait par les entreprises qu'est ce
qui peut et doit être fait au niveau
individuel comment est-ce qu'on rend les
choix de transition écologique aussi que
les citoyens ne font pas confiance aux
politiques pour régler la transition
énergétique
ça veut dire que les citoyens ne font
pas confiance aux politiques tout court
parce que si on rediscute du grand débat
c'est quand même ce qui s'exprime très
fortement une très forte défiance des
citoyens vis-à-vis de leurs élus des
dirigeants et des élus locaux qui se
mobilisent
damien carême le maire de grande synthe
qui a attaqué l'état pour une action
climatique et puis il ya quatorze
communes 14 maires qui vont attaquer
total pour dérèglement climatique pour
non respect de l'accord de paris une
plainte devrait être déposée courant
mars est ce que vous soutiendrez cette
action c'est la plante déposé moi ce que
je soutiens c'est les contrats positif
territoriaux sur l'écologie je suis
vraiment convaincu que la transition
écologique en fait elle se fera sur les
territoires c'est à dire là où des élus
en général des maires ou des communautés
de communes s'engage pour transformer un
programme national qui certes à des
aides et des outils juridiques mais qui
est un peu loin des citoyens en actions
concrètes au bénéfice des citoyens notre
moi ce sont ces actions qui me
paraissent vraiment intéressante y en a
plein en vente avec l'entreprise on peut
toujours attaquée parce que c'est une
forme de protestation c'est aussi une
forme de prise de construire de
conscience mais pour moi c'est plutôt la
construction positive qui fera la
différence on en signent des contrats un
peu partout on est signée à montbard en
bourgogne j'en ai signé dans les
ardennes
il ya des villes qui n'ont pas attendu
de signer ces contrats pour s'engager je
pense à grenoble paris
en pl c'est cette démarche locale je
pense qu'il fera la différence je
poursuis sur total 11 milliards 4 de
bénéfices en 2018
total qui ne veut pas participer pour
baisser le prix des carburants malgré
ses bénéfices très important est ce que
vous trouvez qu au total devrait faire
un geste pour justement aider à cette
transition énergétique mais on a on a
interpellé les grands producteurs
d'énergie en particulier de carburant
quand on trouvait que ça mettait un peu
de temps entre la baisse du prix du
pétrole du baril sur les marchés
internationaux la répercussion à la
pompe
il me semble que patrick pouyanné a dit
qu'avec total access il avait mis en
place un système qui permet de vendre
avec des marges extrêmement faible parce
que c'est important que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités entreprises et à
mêmes citoyens d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya
plein de choses qui peuvent être faites
par des citoyens sans que ça leur coûte
de l'argent qu'ils sont simplement des
changements ne manquent pas demander un
geste à total
il faut demander à total d'être
exemplaire comme n'importe quelle
entreprise qui a une responsabilité et
qui rend compte à ses actionnaires et
moi je rêverais que les actionnaires de
toutes les entreprises pas que total
demande plus de compte sur l'engagement
de l'entreprise en matière de
responsabilité sociale ou transition
politique aldi qui est un centime de
profit par litre d'essence et que donc
faut pas compter sur lui pour un truc à
faire un geste envers les automobilistes
ça vous l'entendez vous verront de
l'entreprise c'est ce que je vous disais
sur le fait qu'il a aussi mis en place
un réseau dans lequel yvan à des prix
avec effectivement des marges très
faibles qui s'appelait total access
décidément ils font dans l'actualité
total qui a annoncé une découverte
importante d'hydrocarbures en afrique du
sud
alors c'est salué par le gouvernement
d'afrique du sud beaucoup moins par le
gouvernement français pour une portion à
parler de drogues dures
nous devons réduire notre dépendance et
le pdg total lui a répondu hier
il ya beaucoup de junkie en france
beaucoup de français veulent utiliser
leur voiture et avoir de l'essence
madame pouvoir sont comprises que lui
répondez-vous aux frais dg de total
moi je suis pas du tout dans l'invectivé
c'est pas mon tempérament aujourd'hui il
y avait encore un sondage qui est sorti
aujourd'hui il ya 40% des français qui
disent qu'ils n'ont pas d'alternative à
la voiture tant qu'on n'est pas capable
de trouver des alternatives
on est dans des débats
principe pour moi l'enjeu c'est qu'on
soit capable de construire des
alternatives au transport mais aussi au
chauffage mais aussi à l'alimentation
qui permette que chacun puisse vraiment
s'engager dans la transition écologique
après on sait que ce l'utilisation des
carburants
c'est l'un des principaux vecteurs de
réchauffement climatique il faut qu'on
arrête aussi vite que possible ça nous
ramène à l'urgence
quatre dernières années sont les quatre
principales l'année de réchauffement
climatique c'est kad années les plus
chaudes depuis 1850
donc ça ramène à la question de
l'urgence mais pour moi la question est
d'arriver à rendre la transition
possible pour les gens notamment pour
les personnes les plus modestes ou
celles qui n'ont pas les moyens de voir
les prix se renchérir en proposant des
solutions donc c'est par les solutions
pour moi qu'on y arrivera en tous les
cas vous êtes tous deux secrétaires
d'état chargé de la transition
écologique au sein du gouvernement hamas
à damas une de trop bien sûr que non et
quand on voit la l'ampleur de la tâche
absolument pas elle est très investi sur
l'économie circulaire et c'est vraiment
un sujet très important moi je travaille
sur les sur les énergies renouvelables
sur les sujets nature non je pense même
qu'on pourrait être encore plus pour
tenter cette belle ambition donc je ne
cautionne politique pour conclure car on
a appris avec nos confrères du poids
c'est une interwiew qui va accorder lui
même ce soir qui se mêlent et mes liens
qu un conseiller très proche du chef de
l'état un conseiller particulier a
décidé de quitter l'elysée son gré le
titre de conseiller spécial je vous
l'apprends oui je n'avais pas vu alors
je découvre ensemble
il part pour de nouvelles aventures
est-ce que c'est selon vous le signe
effectivement que je suis pas le chef de
l'état et peut-être de plus en plus seul
à l'elysée on a vu sa plume parti
récemment sylvain fort comment est-ce
que vous réagissez à chaud il ya des
départs mais il ya aussi des arrivées
l'arrivée de philippe grandjean être
annoncées il n'y a pas très longtemps
que après il ya un renouvellement des
équipes quand on voit le rythme que ses
passings de certaines ou turbulent non
jeu sur leur prêterait pas donc pas à
pas pas de commentaire là dessus ça
annonce un renouvellement au
gouvernement peut-être pour la crise je
crois que là ne m'appartient pas comme
décision merci beaucoup d'avoir et
élections aujourd'hui je vous informe
que le grand débat madame la ministre il
a lieu également sur les chaînes
parlementaires ainsi dès jeudi soir sur
public sénat 18h des sénateurs face aux
citoyens et puis le mercredi de la
semaine prochaine le 20 février ce sera
sur lcp-assemblée nationale à 19h30 donc
le grand débat également sur les chaînes
parlementaires à la semaine prochaine
c'est votre collègue en charge de
l'environnement de l'agriculture pardon
dit des gliomes qui sera l'invité des
gliomes invités d'auditions publiques
bonsoir à tous
[Musique]